and and that's and we're in nature yeah
that's where and where and that's where
we you know they're out there they're
there in cloaks they're in the forest
and these people are literally having
gay sex and coffins okay they're
swimming in feces okay is is this Alex
Jones Harris and your friend Joe Rogan
yeah who's literally reading the George
Soros talking points and he said he'd
have me back on the show I don't need to
be on the show okay well I have sundar
pichai the CEO of Google yeah and Google
is evil and you know this because you're
part of this exact trap travesty is what
I would call it and it's a conspiracy on
what people who come to this planet just
using it as a search engine they're bad
people and they're lizards fat people
and they're not human okay do you have
any Z evidence scientific evidence for
this you have any let me tell you the
scientific evidence that I've found the
bad people of above lizard people
[Laughter]
lizards living among us stuck and your
friend Joe Rogan yeah who and Joe's a
brilliant guy yeah
Joseph Joe knows as much as I do amen
and and he's a well-read guy right and a
nice and he's talking about DMT and he
wants to start a concentration camp no I
don't know I don't think that's strife
don't you a long time I mean where Joe
Rogan where lives up in Valencia where
he has a concentration live in kinda
less concentration tale I can tell you
that the George Soros plant
I got a clam it's just like the story of
the Scorpion and the Frog yeah I know
the Scorpion says hey to the Frog get me
across the water yeah and he gets on the
frog and the scorpion stings the Frog
yeah and the fan of frog says why did
you sting me and he says cuz I'm a
scorpion it's in my nature
you're a it's in my nature you're a
scorpion and a joke Joe Rogan is a
scorpion all right under scorpion people
thanks Alex for joining us and that was
a quick little blurb by Alex Jones and
I said Alex Jones I'm on the PI we have
him on very small blurbs very small
that's too much
he heats up he heats up the room he
literally heats up the room so in his
veins he gets these giant veins and he's
younger than me but bring up Alex Jones
for a second I want to I want to just I
just want to point out that that kind of
agro energy how it is you yeah don't
take all those tones now now alex is 27
years old
yeah he's roughly I think he's 43 or
something that's him and there's no way
he's 40 yeah he's young he's a lot
younger than me but I'm telling you
that's it what's amazing to my chin haha
good are you come now let's go ahead and
look up Alex Jones age because he's and
take a look at him now he's under some
stress because I think he's gonna be in
some Wow look at this you see weeps let
me see it says weeps over Syria all
that's like so 44 oh my god he's brought
war dude
so I are kidding I am eight years older
than him I'm eight years old he's one
year older than me that's right that I I
would have had I would have thought he
was 10 years old I would I would have
thought he was 55 you sure yeah 57 and
then and that's the offense of aluminum
that is in all of our medication I don't
think George soon to sundar Pichai yeah
you who's allowing these communists in
the giant China yeah to censor and edit
okay so that was more Alex on on
aluminum gin so he was creating the
haulage to do oh you have shown yet such
sound Borden gets kind of crazy oh we
should play loud Jones soundboard that's
right that's right make out of frogs gay
[ __ ] make the frogs hey make some frogs
gay it working and they're making the
frogs gay need two different boy well he
likes to he likes to punctuate that
after we you know yeah but they're all
doing various all they are as different
versions of making various he's having a
tough time right now Alex he's sweating
this is what a real human looks like I
like to eat I like to have babies yeah I
like to fight
yeah chin yes sorry and that's a lesson
to the kids out there to keep plugging
at it because they're trying to bury us
and thank God for President Trump who's
gonna take on all this idea malfeasance
and lying CNN think you can get Jim
Acosta
who's out there and I'm Bob wall saying
well there it seems to be peaceful by
the wall you're standing by a wall yeah
whoa which in my sorry Jim
yeah he went crazy on the wall thing
that's that is positive that the Kalen
bloodline runs cold and it's these are
cold-blooded aliens wait a minute and
I've seen it and you go ahead for
Hillary I'd be fog early voted for
Hillary note that she's evil
no and Jen your friend Joe Rogan yeah
who I love Joe okay and we go back a
long time that's right would not have me
back on the show and crazy on the show
and my my calendar the same thing and he
wants to be on your program and you say
you're gonna reboot the brine cab chin
don't play Alex that's right to the
forest having homosexual sex in coffin
all right listen
with John Kerry Jesus turn that and it's
true I know this so much yeah sorry
stop trying to he's like hijacking the
show so here's here's what I would do
and it was like so [ __ ] boring to
talk about it you got to do it well Alex
you can't just stand up comedy I want to
do stand-up comedy
well the juicier friend Joe Rogan said
that I could come out to his
concentration camp he didn't say in
Valencia understand the concentrate all
the people out there and he's harvesting
up their organs no he doesn't and Google
is evil no that's not true and they yep
and sundar Pichai is is is is is is is
is is is put a chip in behind our ear
your friend Joe Rogan
and planning chips it's not as he is I
mean no he's not harvesting organs
he's got good harvest in this Valencia
and he's got a bunch of black market
doctors Harvey he's got them doing Falun
Gong and found off a meditation keeping
their spirit clear and then he's
harvesting the organs and selling it to
George Soros who's vibrating words
around what's he doing with the organ
he's and those are being used for rich
oil magnates oh and they're cauldrons
yes and they're cauldrons and they're
eating too much fatty foods and pork and
and then these health problems and
they're getting a brand-new set of
kidneys from your friend Joe Rogan and I
love Joe and he's a great guy he's
smarter than me but you're saying he's
got something he knows just as much as I
do
no and he's implanting into chips so
until chin I mean there's only a few
minutes left no rules bribed calendars
Elton no for me it goes to Phuket
Thailand probably with Jeff Bezos and
Jill rogue won't believe the girl to be
14 at the time the tape was recorded
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]